Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new mandalorian season 2 episode 8
post credit scene video for all that stuff that
they set up in the big spin-off series so i'll
explain what's going on there was so much
confusion after that post credit scene aired
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos i will be doing episode
videos for all the big mandalorian spin-off
series that they've announced i'll also explain
what's going on with the schedule of episodes for
mandalorian season 3 and all the other spin-off
series at the end of the video too we'll do a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know which mandalorian spin-off series you're most
hyped about i know everyone's really excited to
see what they do with the ahsoka tano series and
to get our first look at grand admiral thrawn but
careful for spoilers for everything that happened
during the mandalorian season 2 episode 8 finale
if you haven't seen the episode yet because there
were some major major reveals but just starting
with the big stuff after the mandalorian season
2 episode 8 there was a boba fett post credit
scene meant to be a teaser for his new mini-series
that's coming next december the book of boba fett
per the title cards it's a mini-series probably
because it's a one-and-done thing and it won't
be as many episodes as a typical season of the
mandalorian i'll talk about why that is in a
second because it has a lot to do with what
lucasfilm confirmed about the schedule next year
at the big disney investor day the scene picks up
sometime recently after the events of the rescue
mission to save grogu to help bokehtan get the
light cruiser and the darksaber they accomplished
most of those goals mission mostly accomplished
because now per the mandalorian customs mando
himself won the darksaber from moff gideon meaning
he now has the strongest claim to the throne of
mandalore so shout out to jon snow because pedro
pascal was also a character on game of thrones he
doesn't want it and daenerys targaryen Bo Katan
here has to have it out with him to decide what
they're gonna do next about this because obviously
that's gonna be plot during the mandalorian season
3 that they'll cover episodes of that get this are
also coming december next year so i know there's
a lot of confusion because the title card for the
book of boba fett also said coming december 2021
but now we have the mandalorian season 3 boba fett
ahsoka tano series and the rangers of the new
republic series that'll all be happening during
the same time period and crossing over with each
other like netflix defenders or avengers end game
avengers infinity war make whatever reference you
want but number nine boba fett and fenix shand
return to jabba's palace under twin sons i also
love that they played the twin sons theme song
when luke entered at the end of the episode
because it's kind of luke skywalker's theme
in the star wars universe as well we find that bib
fortuna and some of jabba's court from return of
the jedi survive the sarlacc pit event in the
sail barge explosion and bib fortuna has taken
jabba's throne literally and metaphorically
metaphorically because he's slowly getting
thicker and thicker like jabba fun fact too if you
haven't read any of the classic expanded universe
novels or watched the clone wars episodes like
tales from jabba's palace there are other books
and stories that cover job of the hutt's history
in his own rise to power more of his family of
huts are also featured during the clone wars
episodes his mother and his uncle zero the hut
his mother is actually even larger and way more
powerful in the crime syndicates than jabba was
jabba was very powerful so i'll talk about that
when we talk about the plot of this boba fett
mini-series but it's only been about six years
since the sail barge exploded in return of the
jedi so bib fortuna hasn't been running jabba's
criminal empire for that long fenix shand enters
killing all the weak way guards and the others
then frees his replacement twilight slave girl
remember bib fortune is a twilike himself so he's
kind of despicable keeping one of his own people
as a slave girl they still love the rancor pit i
love the way that boba fett just walks and stands
on the grill but he knows that there's no more
rancor press f in the chat to pay respects the
rancor did nothing wrong he was a good boy and
also side note rancors are native to dathomir the
night sisters domesticate them and grand admiral
thrawn's lackey morgan ellsbeth from season 2
episode 5 was also from dathomir during the clone
wars before it was destroyed darth maul also was
born on dathomir as one of the knight brothers
they're like the breeding stock for the night
sisters because it's more of a matriarchy there so
hopefully at some point in these new live-action
series we'll see some night sisters show up but
as biv fortuna is crapping his pants on the throne
there in surprise boba fett slowly walks down the
steps and here's this really important attention
to detail that i thought was really cool you
probably heard this if you were watching the
episode in a quiet room or you weren't cheering
too loudly over the episode because it was a
great episode there's very little music as he's
walking down the steps because they want you to
hear the jingle of the spurs on his boots just
like classic boba fett from empire strikes back
i don't think you're actually able to hear the
spurs during return of the jedi because most of
the scenes of boba fett are of him standing around
and when he is moving around it's really noisy so
you can't really hear it part of the magic of the
mandalorian episodes has been jon favreau and dave
filoni's attention to little details like that
their easter eggs even in some of the sound design
and because we're talking about classic boba fett
from the original trilogy we should also say again
jeremy bullock the original boba fett actor
passed away last week the day before the finale
episode aired the cast and crew were paying their
respects on social media so if you wondered what
was going on that was why but in a classic boba
fett move true to og boba fett bib fortuna starts
sputtering a mile a minute trying to talk
his way out of the situation and without
saying a single word boba fett just shoots
him dead on the spot pushes his thick body
off the throne and sits down looking very
comfortable as the camera pans out ludwig
gordenson the person that does all the music for
the mandalorian series which is amazing plays a
darker boba fett version of the mandalorian theme
which may or may not be part of the theme song for
the boba fett show he might make something totally
different when they actually get to those episodes
i also love ming na's performance here at the
end too fenix shan grabs the bottle of the blue
sorghum booze that everybody in the star wars
galaxy drinks it shows up on the series in a
bunch of different planets it's made from the
blue krill that they've farmed in that village
from the mandalorian season 1 episode 4. so it's
like the official booze of the star wars universe
but she just shrugs takes a giant swig from the
bottle and sits down on the arm of the throne
then the title card reads the book of boba fett
coming december 2021 so here's the thing about
the book of boba fett because the vast majority
of fans myself included just for a little while
last night were confused about what that
meant for the mandalorian season 3 next year
especially because the way they left things
with mando and the other main characters from
the mandalorian you have grogu leaving with luke
skywalker to train as a jedi then you have mando
joining up with bo katan to take back mandalore
and deal with the darksaber everyone was confused
as to whether or not the book of boba fett was
meant to be the mandalorian season 3 and would
the episodes just follow his story for a little
while and mando be a side character or would boba
fett be a full spin-off series in addition to the
mandalorian season 3 because the star wars people
at that big disney investor day confirmed that
the mandalorian season 3 episode 1 would release
christmas 2021 then we get this title card
saying the book of boba fett coming december 2021
so lucasfilm has not said anything about
this on their official social media accounts
i think the reason for that is because they don't
want to spoil the post credit scene so they're
probably waiting till next week to start talking
about the boba fett series and that's why they
didn't announce it back at the disney investor day
because they didn't want to play their hand too
soon like oh yeah we have this boba fett thing
coming up so he's definitely not going to die
during the finale right now the hollywood reporter
is the only big trade publication that's claiming
that the book of boba fett is a full spin-off show
in addition to the mandalorian season 3 but i do
believe that that's true and what will happen is
is because the boba fett series is meant to be a
mini series they'll just do four episodes of that
and they'll start it at the beginning of december
it'll run for four weeks and then that'll get us
to christmas when mandalorian season 3 starts and
they'll air that for eight weeks and it'll run
for eight episodes like it normally would so
next year we're actually going to get 12 episodes
of live action star wars series between boba fett
and mandalorian season 3 but remember because
they air episodes weekly mandalorian season 3
is going to spill well into february but what's
actually happening with the plot of this boba fett
series so it seems like what they're doing just in
general with the character on the mandalorian is
turning him into the badass we always thought he
was that he was hyped to be in empire strikes back
but that the star wars movies then never really
delivered on so call it the redemption of boba
fett is the most fearsome bounty hunter in the
galaxy because it sounds like mando isn't going
to be hunting a whole lot of bounties in mando
season 3 per Bo Katan like you're a common bounty
hunter you need to serve a higher calling which
it sounds like mando is now doing and now it seems
like boba fett is styling himself as one of the
most powerful crime lords in the galaxy as well
so the boba fett series sounds like it's going
to be more like the classic tales from jabba's
palace books and if you remember the original
live-action star wars underworld series that
george lucas tried to get made right after revenge
of the sith a long time ago there was a pilot and
a bunch of footage from it that leaked online i
did a whole video for it so i'll link that in the
description that wound up being cancelled because
at the time the special effects technology wasn't
as easy as it was to do today way more expensive
and the budget would have been way too big
but it would have followed the criminal underworld
of coruscant and the rest of the galaxy so that's
probably what the boba fett show is going to
feel like also really important detail like i
said all the mandalorian episodes and spin-off
shows all 3 of them now if you include the new
boba fett miniseries will cross over with each
other and build towards an event that lucasfilm
and the star wars people were calling a huge event
series the villain of that as you probably guessed
because they took down moff gideon pretty quickly
in the finale will be grand admiral thrawn the new
big bad of the star wars universe during this era
of the timeline we didn't actually see live-action
thrawn during the mandalorian finale so my
assumption is is that we'll see him on screen for
the first time during the asocatano series because
he got the big shout out during ahsoka's episode
when that premieres probably 2022 at some point
they'll probably wait to cast a thrawn actor till
they start filming next year i've already done
a couple videos for grand admiral thrawn in the
mandalorian live action series so i'll link one
of those in the description below too but we've
been talking about them doing an heir to the
empire thrawn trilogy in the live-action movies
for a long time now it sounds like that's what
they're doing through these live-action series
like there was a big jedi cloning plot during the
thrawn trilogy involving luke and another jedi now
we have all this cloning stuff going on with grogu
it seems like they're borrowing a lot of elements
from the thrawn trilogy but we'll probably find
out who's playing thrawn before the mandalorian
season 3 and the boba fett episodes drop next
year they haven't said exactly when they're
gonna be filming everything but that's usually
when you find this stuff out and even though boba
fett teamed up with mando during season 2 really
important remember historically he's been pretty
morally ambiguous even portrayed as a villain
technically he's not really a villain though
he's just a simple man trying to make his way in
the universe so i'm expecting him to be way more
down and dirty on his mini-series but ultimately
will wind up helping mando bo katan and ahsoka
take down grand admiral thrawn and because he's
running this criminal enterprise now make a tidy
sum in the process kind of like a darker version
of lando calrissian someone who's viewed as an
ally to the good guys but also runs a lot of shady
business on the side remember they're businessmen
there's also a live-action lando calrissian series
that they're making but it's supposed to follow
young lando donald glover's version of the
character and i don't know when they plan on
releasing that but the ahsoka tano episodes in the
rangers the new republic series will all probably
be released during 2022 along with the obi-wan
kenobi episodes shout out to hayden christensen
finally coming back and the rogue one prequel
series episodes for star wars and or what that
means though and some of you have probably done
the math on this is that the mandalorian season
4 might not premiere until early 2023 because
with the schedule that they're on right now
they're barely getting season 3 episode 1 out by
christmas next year so the schedule is just moving
further and further back but the mandalorian
season 3 is going to cover all that bokeh tan
versus mando darksaber stuff that they set up
all the grogu jedi training with luke skywalker
and now mando is in the service of Bo Katan and
the other mandalorians as they continue to try
and rebuild their fleet in their weaponry but
because of the timing of everything and when all
the series are dropping that big final battle with
grand admiral thrawn probably won't happen to like
the mandalorian season 5 in a couple more years
even though we'll meet thrawn long before that
right now they're filming the boba fett series and
mando season 3 is getting ready to start filming
my next video will be for the mandalorian season
3 all those story lines and what's happening next
with all the characters then after that i'll do
like a really big luke skywalker mandalorian video
because there are huge ramifications for them
going full original trilogy with luke skywalker
cameos if they're going that far think about what
that means for hayden christensen coming back and
the potential for him to also show up during the
ahsoka tano series i'll name a giveaway winner
when i post that mando season 3 video tomorrow
but everyone click here for my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 8 finale video and click here for
my video about hayden christensen coming back as
darth vader and anakin skywalker thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!